welcome back everybody uh this is a
an incredible sort of leak here it looks
like it's coming out of reddit it it is
something that was originally posted
back in august of 2021 uh and it looks
like we have some confirmation through
the trailer that was released on sunday
it is rather accurate um a few things
here and there aren't uh but it seems to
be possible
reshoots or changes that were made but
ultimately it's very accurate for
something that was originally again
posted uh back in august
let's get started
opened in a fiery burn forest mordo is
hunting wanda with a magical bow wanda
chops off his head
wang is the sorcerer supreme confirmed
and no way home
then we have a multiverse chase with
chavez wong and a variant looking
strange which is most likely defender
strange
they run away from an interdimensional
demon and are on route to retrieve a
book that will grant them a spell to
defeat any evil they get close but are
impaled
chavez takes strange's dead body and
multiverse hops to our main universe
when she is anxious and scared she can
open multiverse portals and is the only
person able to back to our timeline
strange and wong are at palmer's wedding
when schuma gorath obviously most likely
quirk gargantos uh was mistaken for
schuman gorham starts attacking new york
city she is trying to harvest america's
power and was summoned by wanda
strange and wong fight schuma people in
cars die by being smashed wong and
strange are able to kill it by ripping
its eye out chavez meets them and takes
them to strange's dead body in an
alleyway they then go to a pizza shop to
calm chavez down strange starts having
nightmares about dying with wong chavez
explains that they are not dreams of
real events happening in other realities
she also talks about how she is always
on the run from some monster strange
thinks wanna can help one threatens
strange and they go to comartage to
protect chavez we are introduced to
rintra wanna kills lots of people and is
able to capture wang but strange and
chavez escaped to another universe wanda
can actually project herself to other
universes but can't bring her body we
see strange and chavez in an iron legion
timeline as strange is looking for help
then they go to a timeline where strange
sacrificed himself to defeat thanos they
go to the sanctum where mordor is the
sorcerer's supreme he poisons strange
and chavez they wake up in a prison
mordo brings him to the rest of the
illuminati which is a multiverse team
that consists of monica rambo as captain
marvel captain carter balder the brave
and professor x as their leader the
illuminati debate on whether or not to
kill strange because he is breaching the
universe which is forbidden strange
warns that wanda is coming we then see
wanda from the illuminati timeline with
her kids but mcuana possesses the varian
kids are confused as wanda just leaves
to see the illuminati mulder says wanda
is no match for them and wanda just
impales his body with magic xavier has
his floating chair monica and carter are
crushed by falling statues or thrown to
a wall can't remember which palmer
breaks chavez out of prison as one and
xavier fight
he tries to heal her but she snaps his
neck strange and mordo fight but i can't
remember how it ends palmer strange and
chavez go to an underground sanctum
running away from wanda one is blowing
stuff up as she gets close to them they
reach a locked door and palmer is able
to open it with the help from her
bracelet the sword opens to the
multiverse and we see the book they try
to reach the book but wanna grabs chavez
and throws strange and palmer to another
timeline it is a decimated new york city
where defender strange is the ruler of
the sanctum at the camartage sorcerers
create a magic barrier to prevent juana
from getting in she answers the mind of
a new weak sorcerer and breaks the spell
killing 95 percent of all sorcerers one
is now back at the camartage with chavez
and a sorcerer sacrifices herself to
destroy the darkhold wanda threatens
wang to tell her where she can find
another darkhold otherwise she will
destroy existence wong informs her of a
dark hole up in the mountains in an
unknown place they go to the castle
where there are dark hold and demonic
etchings on the wall wanda now has
chavez's power and the darkhold and can
now multiverse hop her physical self to
her kids and bring them to her universe
evil wanda beats good wanda and she
reaches her children from this timeline
while this happens strange fights
defender strange strange kills him by
throwing defender strange out of a
window and getting impaled on a fence
strange astral projects himself to his
dead self in the main timeline he walks
like a zombie then we have a scene at
the camartage with a few survivors as
rintra gives a speech about how wong
never gave up on them
they make a trip to the dark cold castle
as they make the trip up there wang is
thrown out of the castle but uses magic
to save himself strange whispers and
chaves his ear with this dead cell this
imbues chavez with better control of her
multiverse powers and she punches wanda
in and out of different universes as
wanda punches her back to other
universes wanda finally getting to her
kids but she is so messed up and zombie
looking that her kids cry as she comes
to them wanda blows up the darkhold
domain when she comes to her senses
after seeing her kids frightened we see
her in the rubble and clear if she lives
or dies probably lives we have a
dialogue with chavez and strange whether
she is happy strange came back strange
bows to wong and they trained chavez to
hone her skills further billy and tommy
are in the movie and they are aged up at
the end five distinct universes and a
few weird ones illuminati timeline
ruined new york city iron legion and the
multiverse itself one that looks like
the end of loki and a dark old castle
which takes place in the main timeline
but is located in an unknown place
post-credit is strange getting corrupted
and growing a third eye out of his head
as clea asks for help
and that's pretty much it thank you so
much to everyone that did stick around
that was a long one i really appreciate
uh you guys listening to it because
it is pretty accurate when it does
coincide with the trailer that was
released and ultimately i mean if this
ruins it for you i'm so sorry but uh it
looks like it may actually be going this
way
a few changes here and there obviously
because
this was released back in august and as
you know marvel tends to change things
and we still got a couple more months to
go until we see this movie so
do me a favor let me know in the
comments uh what you guys think are you
guys excited still and like this video
if you do
subscribe if you can and i'll see you
guys tomorrow
you